next we have some information for you
about the pokemon legends arceus game
which is being developed by gamefreak
[Music]
[Music]
great
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh
that was the latest trailer for pokemon
legends arceus
let's take a closer look at some of the
elements introduced in the video
pokemon legends arceus is a brand new
title that opens new doors for the
pokemon series by fusing action with rpg
elements
your adventure takes place in a region
known as isui during a long ago era when
it was rare for people to live in
harmony alongside pokemon
mount coronet towers over the center of
the land with sprawling diverse natural
environments surrounding the mountain on
all sides
these different areas are home to a rich
variety of pokemon ecosystems
in the future this land of hissui will
come to be known as the sinnoh region
you'll set out on an adventure with the
goal of completing the first ever
pokedex for the hisoui region
[Music]
the bustling jubilee village would be
the base for your adventures
it's home to the galaxy expedition team
made up of people from various other
regions
with divisions such as the medical corps
the security corps and the survey corps
which researches pokemon
professor lavinton's field of study is
the ecology of pokemon he came to the
hisui region along with pokemon he met
in various other regions he entrusts one
of these pokemon to you
captain cylene is the leader of the
survey corps though she may seem to
treat you harshly deep down she's your
biggest supporter and she watches over
your progress with care
commander commodo oversees the entire
galaxy team he's a dependable leader who
has earned the unwavering trust of his
team members when the commander
recognizes your knack for pokemon
research he allows you to join the team
and has you work as a member of the
survey corps
the duty of the survey corps is to
observe and catch pokemon to shed light
on how they live
your survey duties hold the key to
unlocking the true purpose of your
adventure and in the course of your work
you'll visit various locations within
the hisui region
your excursions outside the village will
begin by preparing at a base camp at
these camps you'll be able to prepare
for your survey work by buying items or
crafting new ones from basic materials
in the hisui region you'll find that
you'll be vulnerable to attacks from
wild pokemon take too much damage from
their attacks and you'll black out so
use caution when you're out doing your
survey work
when your pokemon are hurt you can
return to a base camp to rest up and
recover
once you've completed a survey
assignment return to the village and
report the results to whoever requested
the job
pokemon live all over the place
get close to them and aim carefully then
throw a pokeball to try to catch them
you'll find that not all species of
pokemon react the same way when they
spot you
for example some pokemon will
immediately flee so you'll want to hide
in tall grass when you approach them
aggressive pokemon on the other hand may
need to be weakened in battle there are
a variety of tricks to catching them all
[Music]
throw a pokeball containing one of your
own pokemon near a wild pokemon and a
battle will begin
you'll find that a single pokemon may
get to act multiple times in a row
depending on its speed stat and the
moves that it uses you can also choose
to have pokemon use their moves in two
different styles strong style and agile
style
using a move in a strong style will
increase the move's power but the
pokemon's action speed will be lowered
using a move in the agile style will
decrease the moves power but the
pokemon's action speed will be raised
you'll find the strong style will come
in handy when you see a chance to end a
battle with one powerful move while the
agile style is great for situations
where acting multiple times in a row
will give your battle strategy a real
boost use these different styles as the
situation demands to gain the upper hand
in battle
when you report the results of your
survey work to the professor information
will be added to the pokedex
you can advance your research and fill
in more information by doing things like
catching pokemon seeing them use certain
moves multiple times and more seek out
and meet lots of different pokemon to
complete that pokedex
[Music]
now we'd like to introduce some of the
pokemon living in the rich natural
environments that are spread out across
the hisui region
this pokemon with distinctive antlers is
known as weirdier weirdier evolves from
a stantler that has managed to live in
the harsh natural environment of the
hisoui region
it has strong ties with the local people
and it has been treated with great care
and respect in this land since ancient
times
garments made with the first shed from
its beard tail and legs are highly
prized as warm winter clothing
this pokemon is basky legion it can swim
with great power masculine that live in
the hisui region can evolve into this
pokemon if they become possessed by the
restless souls of other masculine in
their school that have perished during
their journey upstream this pokemon
gains power from the souls possessing it
letting it swim on and on without tiring
there are also pokemon that can be found
living in this land in forms that have
adapted to the environment of the hisui
region
this pokemon with its great majestic
wings is the hissuian form of braviary
it comes to hissui in the winter and can
imbue its screeches with psychic power
to generate shockwaves
this pokemon which works with a partner
is the hisoian form of growlithe it is a
very weary pokemon and appears to
protect its territory kisuyun growless
soft fur is an excellent insulator
allowing it to stay active and lively
even in this chilly land the horn on its
head is made of rock but it breaks
easily so heisuy and growlith uses it
only when it'll have the greatest effect
the pokemon arceus holds the key to this
story but what connection does it have
to your adventure
we hope you look forward to finding out
on the day when you can finally meet the
people and pokemon of the hi-sui region
for yourself
those were